la guerre économique et commerciale
entre la chine et les etats-unis les
présidentes donald trump exige in ping
s'affrontent à coups de droits de douane
et de sanctions quid de la france et de
l'union européenne dans ce conflit c'est
le thème du colloque organisé par
l'association génération entreprise
présidée par olivier dassault et jean
michel fourgous avec la question du
patriotisme économique
on a souvent assimilé le patriotisme
économique au protectionnisme c'est pas
du tout la même chose protectionnisme
c'est le repli complet sur soi c'est la
mythologie de l'autosuffisance du
patriotisme économique ce n'est jamais
que la défense et la promotion de nos
intérêts économiques qui en particulier
industrielles dans le respect du
principe de réciprocité est ce qui fait
d'ailleurs part jean michel fourgous
dans le bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines participe justement de la
promotion de ce patriotisme économique
auquel je suis si attaché airbus thalès
ou encore safran plusieurs leaders
industriels installés sur saint quentin
en yvelines des géants français et
européens mais insuffisant selon bernard
carayon je crois qu'il manque encore
d'une vraie politique industrielle en
europe et cette politique industrielle
aujourd'hui elle est entravée par la
politique de la concurrence qui
repêchent nos grands doutes de ceux
constituant mastodonte pour affronter
justement les mastodontes américains
indiens ou chinois
autre sujet abordé la cybersécurité avec
un engagement particulier de saint
quentin en yvelines pour soutenir la
formation dans ce domaine
les formations en tout cas en
cybersécurité nous on mélange est très
belles boîtes les plus belles boîtes
françaises sur la cybersécurité sur le
numérique avec des jeunes et des moins
jeunes et des écoles qui veulent réussir
donc voilà c'est ce ce mariage subtil
qui fera la pertinence certainement de
la réussite de la france qui se
protégera dans cette révolution
la cyber sécurité un enjeu important
dans un contexte de guerre économique
d'après les prévisions le nombre de
cyberattaques devrait augmenter de 500 %
d'ici à 2020